[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti pour le sommaire
cyclisme la finale de la coupe d'hiver
était programmé ce dimanche 27 janvier
au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plus de 130
cyclistes sont venus de la région pour
participer à l'événement et notamment
des féminines plus de détails dans ce
magazine
ils se portent pour la deuxième année
consécutive un tournoi de sport
électronique était organisée à l'hôtel
de ville de versailles
les dizaines de joueurs professionnels
ou amateurs se sont affrontés sur le jeu
de cartes virtuelles houston reportage à
suivre automobile l'illinois tristan
couedel a réussi à terminer la course
africa et corey saint valley dans le
désert africain il reviendra sur son
expérience dans ce magazine l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres on
commence par une mauvaise nouvelle pour
le monde de l'équitation le jumping
international de versailles est
officiellement annulée
le concours de saut d'obstacles 5
étoiles devait avoir lieu au mois
d'avril dans les écuries en face du
château organisé une première fois en
2010 est plus annuler en 2018 faute de
date disponible les organisateurs ont
cette fois ci évoquer une conjoncture
actuelle compliqué l'événement est donc
reporté à l'année prochaine si tous les
éléments sont réunis en 2010 est le
rendez-vous avait permis d'attirer les
meilleurs cavaliers à mondiaux on
continue à part du cyclisme à la demie
la finale de la coupe d'hiver était
programmé ce dimanche au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'occasion de regrouper les meilleurs
cyclistes venus de la région ile de
france et notamment des féminines un
reportage signé et xavier jaglin honte
troisième finale de la coupe d'hiver au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la compétition au groupe et cette année
8 franciliens de la catégorie minime aux
élites événement est en pleine expansion
elle est passé de 90 à plus de 130
participants depuis sa création
ça fait partie des objectifs de beaucoup
de coureurs et de beaucoup de pistard et
cette coupe d'hiver fait partie de d'une
très bonne préparation et pour certains
ils vont attaquer les épreuves sur route
notamment les coureurs d'endurance pour
attaquer les épreuves sur route dans un
mois et donc c'est une excellente
préparation à la piste parmi ces
coureurs présents ont retrouvé 24
féminine sur la piste une première pour
l'événement marine cloarec du club de
plus tôt n'a pas hésité à participation
rendez vous au vélodrome nationale pour
promouvoir le cyclisme sur piste féminin
ça nous permet de vous mettre en avant
et de voir que le cyclisme féminin
attend
si à faire de la piste et que voilà on
est on a quand même un niveau et que on
a notre place ainsi plus dans le
cyclisme sorti une nouvelle édition
devrait être organisée l'année prochaine
des manches supplémentaires pourraient
être ajoutés objectif pérenniser
l'événement dans le temps un moderne
balle à présent dans le championnat de
nationale 3 plaisir s'offre une bouffée
d'oxygène à la lutte pour le maintien
les plaisirs oies se sont largement
imposés face à thionville moselle ce
dimanche à domicile le score 33 à 24 au
classement plaisir sort de la zone de
relégation avec deux points d'avancé sur
son adversaire du jour qui est également
le premier relégable toujours handball
dans le championnat de nationale 2
féminin rien n'arrête montigny le
bretonneux les filles de denys choulet
se sont imposés pour la troisième fois
consécutive en 2019 leurs victimes du
jour stella sport sa mort
le score est lui à sans appel 24 à 18
pour les îles monteyne un résultat qui
permet à montigny le bretonneux de
s'emparer de la septième place et de
revenir à quatre points du podium
si on a pu jouer dans les gymnases
c'était beaucoup plus compliqué sur les
terrains de football une grande partie
des rencontres ont été reportées
on a tout de même joué en première
division de district du côté de
guyancourt réduit en courtois se sont
d'ailleurs imposés à domicile 3-1 face
aux chaînés ce dimanche cette victoire
leur permet de s'emparer de la première
place du championnat après douze
journées à disputer
il y avait également du rugby ce
dimanche plaisir s'est incliné dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 leurs
bourreaux du jour le rcbb 15 les pzero
hadrons été battu 30 à 7 sur leur
terrain face à un poids lourd du
championnat
au classement le psg reste tout de même
à cinq points de la zone de relégation
et peut espérer se maintenir en fin de
saison on prend maintenant la direction
de versailles pour la deuxième année
consécutive un tournoi de heath portes
du sport électronique était organisée à
l'hôtel de ville de la commune des
dizaines de joueurs professionnels ou
amateurs se sont affrontés sur le jeu de
cartes virtuelles stone des images de à
nicolas d'henri des écrans des partis
qui se joue à la dernière seconde
bienvenue sur un tournoi de nice porte
sur le jeu heures stone a rendez vous
organisé à l'hôtel de ville de
versailles ce jeu est considéré
aujourd'hui comme un sport à part
entière
tiens je garde donc
ça va se rapprocher plutôt des échecs je
dirais il ya les jeux vidéos qui sont
beaucoup plus dynamique beaucoup plus
basé sur l'orbité l'on ne sait vraiment
un jeu de réflexion qui est donc un jeu
créé de l'univers de world of warcraft
grippe a raté de plus au grand public et
le but ça va être avec son deck sa
bibliothèque de cartes de trente cartes
d'être le premier à réussir à détruire
son adversaire ce jeu a également ses
champions dans ce tournoi vers seyant
pouvait trouver michael dowse alias
maverick l'un des meilleurs joueurs
français en activité et s'est lancé dans
la discipline il y a quatre ans comme un
athlète de haut niveau
j'aime pas vraiment la presse sports
mais il ya beaucoup de similitudes c'est
à dire qu'on s'entraîne beaucoup on
analyse nos matches être capable d'être
concentré tout le monde leur match et
même de plusieurs matches qu'on doit
jouer plusieurs sur une journée c'est
pas toujours quelque chose de facile
même bien boire entre les matchs etc
ces deux réflexes que tout le monde n'a
pas et qui sont très importants qu'on
veut faire la différence au tous niveaux
et comme pour tout sport de haut niveau
cette discipline a de nombreux fans
certains étaient présents à l'hôtel de
ville de versailles
robben comme c'est aussi des gens qu'on
rencontre qu'on peut voir à l'ordinateur
en sur twitter en streaming un peu de
contrats et donc c'est vraiment sympa de
les voir aussi en vrais adversaires
comme aujourd'hui
au total au rendez vous a réuni encore
cette année plus de 500 passionnés une
nouvelle édition devrait être organisée
l'année prochaine on ouvre maintenant
une page sport automobile nous vous
avions promis qu'il reviendrait sur ce
plateau s'il arrivait à terminer
l'africa eco reis un rallye automobile
en afrique et c'est ce qu'il a réussi à
faire le pilote tristan couëdel de la
petite ville de blary chiens nous fait
l'honneur de revenir sur ce plateau
bonsoir tristan bonsoir alors j'imagine
que vous êtes très heureux d'avoir
terminé c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
bonheur beaucoup d'émotion commence à
digérer un petit peu avec mon copilote
mais c'est vrai que voilà ça a été d'une
intensité à la fois en termes
d'investissement pendant la course parce
que ça a été difficile mais c'est en s'y
attendait et puis aussi le bonheur
absolu d'être enfin l'arrivée et voilà
dans de bonnes conditions donc c'était
super votre aventure elle s'est passé
comment plutôt bien finalement alors oui
bien en fait le
l'arrivée à dakar sur la plage fait tout
oublier après les jours on était long
intense
on a fini beaucoup de spéciales de nuit
et pour résumer un petit peu on passait
entre 10 et 11 heures par jour dans la
voiture et entre 3 et 6 heures sous la
voiture en arrivant au bivouac puisque
comme on était parti sans assistance
voilà nous faisions nous mêmes notre
mécanique quoi vous n'étiez pas au même
niveau que les têtes d affiches
annoncent bien sûr bien sûr les mais bon
ça ç'a un impact un petit peu sur toute
la journée puisque finalement c'est
aussi que les seconds qu'on peut gagner
dans le désert on risque de les perdre
le soir donc en fait c'est aussi une
balance et on essaye de conduire entre
guillemets intelligemment
comment avez vous trouvé le tracé
absolument génial on s'est régalé je
croyais connaître tous les paysages du
maroc c'était très présomptueux parce
qu'on a vu des choses et que sans ça y
est le sable à la fin non non non parce
qu'on a eu beaucoup de chance dans le
sable en lui même dans les dunes notre
voiture était exceptionnelle on n'a plus
payé sur la piste sur des endroits avec
beaucoup de poussière et des parcours
très très long 606 120 kilomètres dans
le désert c'est long c'est dur mais
voilà ça c'est ça c'est terminé
quelle est la plus grosse difficulté que
vous ayez rencontré dans ces dunes
mauritanie notamment une spéciale qui
était d'une longueur incroyable on a
fini de nuit dans les dunes avec des
dunes qui était cassante donc on sait
jamais trop ce qui se passe et des
voitures en fait après avoir tranché la
d'une tombe quasiment la verticale et ça
avec la nuit la rampe de phares on
finissait par se demander où on était
quoi c'était assez surréaliste en fait
alors vous avez terminé 21e au général
est ce que c'est un résultat inattendu
oui l'aviez dit ah ben ça plate au que
vous vouliez juste participer à
l'événement et finalement vous terminé
21e exactement parce qu'en fait de parra
le travail de mon copilote aussi très
assidus on a eu chaud les waypoints on
n'a jamais été aidé par quiconque
on a fini toutes nos spéciale du coup
par le
l'absence absolue de pénalité du coup en
petit à petit au fil des jours normaux
durant classement et on finit 10e
automobile est premier de notre
catégorie
c'était pas du tout une volonté de notre
part c'est véritablement le voilà le jeu
de la régularité qui a payé en fait la
voiture était au point
il a fallu travailler encore un petit
petit alors je vous l'avais évoqué
j'avais quelques doutes
on a fini de la m poids y compris
parfois sur la piste puisqu'on a perdu
aussi du temps on a eu pas mal de leurs
ennuis mécaniques sur la piste mais on
avait pris beaucoup d'outils on est
quasiment 80 kg de matériel embarqué ce
qui ne se fait pas normalement une
voiture de course mais c'est vrai que ça
nous a perdu justement de terminer
toutes nos spéciales et du coup de ne
pas prendre de pénalité donc au final de
faire un bon résultat
il ya un moment où vous étiez sur le
point d'abandonner ou pas du tout on a
eu des vérités sur un trou de la course
sera un an
il ya trois fois ou réellement on s'est
dit que c'était la fin et notamment le
premier soir où on heureusement une
équipe d'anglet nous ont donné un coup
de main incroyable ils nous ont fabriqué
une pièce entre minuit et 2h du matin
qui nous a permis le lendemain de
repartir parce que très honnêtement
l'agent n'avait pas de solution en
interne et donc c'est une équipe
clin d'oeil qu'on a beaucoup aidés après
dans le sable puisque leurs équipages
avaient des problèmes à passer dans le
sable donc on les a tracté au moins une
sept ou huit fois et donc on a pu enfin
leur rendre la pareille mais c'est grâce
à eux aussi qu'on a pu terminer la
course quoi il faut avoir l'esprit
l'équipe pour participer à ce jour d'
aventure non des partis dans cette
logique du dakar tel qu'il nous a hanté
et qui nous a fait rêver pendant des
années et on l'a vécu comme ça on a aidé
certains de nos concurrents qui aurait
pu
nous prendre notre première place de
catégorie on l'a fait on l'a vécu
pleinement de dakar on s'est régalé et
voilà beaucoup d'émotion à l'arrivée
c'était juste génial quoi vous aviez
participé au dakar il ya vingt ans vous
aviez abandonné là finalement vingt ans
après c'est un beau clin d'oeil oui
c'était extraordinaire parce que j'avais
vécu cette aventure - il ya 20 ans un
peu durban parce que parce que voilà je
m'étais investi beaucoup qu'en gt gt
vingt ans plus jeune donc j'avais toute
cette fougue et ça avait une vraie
déception est là c'est extraordinaire
sur la plage de dakar j'ai appelé la
personne avec qui je l'avais fait il ya
vingt ans et voilà je l' ai dit voilà je
les en y est on y est moins souvent
associé et ami et co pilote avait lui
aussi une aventure il ya vingt ans dans
le désert dans ces mêmes pays et donc il
y avait toute une symbolique qui était
extra aussi en plus est ce que justement
cette expérience vous a permis de
terminer cette fois ci oui on a beaucoup
progressé en a mis en place d'études
vous perdiez dans les premiers jours de
compétition oui et l'ins est vrai que
petit à petit on a installé des choses
sérieuse de des rigueurs de
fonctionnement des routines quand on se
perdait notamment parce que les épreuves
de navigation sont difficiles aussi et
mon copilote a remarquablement bien
navigué mais voilà quand on avait des
moments de doute on a appris à
travailler ensemble à s'arrêter refaire
un point repartir et c'est difficile
quand on est en course parce que on a
cette excitation et au contraire c'est
l'hyper lucidité qui fait qu' on arrive
au bout dans de bonnes conditions
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus émerveillé
pendant ce périple probablement des
paysages que ce soit au maroc ou en
mauritanie
le passage de la frontière qui est
absolument surréaliste où vous avez vécu
pendant cinq jours dans un désert
excessivement sec et la mauritanie la
vous franchissez le fleuve sénégal
vous arrivez au sénégal et là tout
change
c'est enfin on a l'impression que voilà
le lot c'est la vie et en ce passage-là
de frontières étaient impressionnants
quoi
quels sont vos prochains objectifs
tristan est ce que voulait repartir sur
l'africa eco race ou peut-être le dakar
c'est tout l'enjeu
très honnêtement on y réfléchit on y
réfléchit mais voilà cette expérience
nous a galvanisés et on veut aller au
bout d'autres rêves dans le voilà on est
en train de se mettre d'accord sur nos
futurs projets voilà le prochain dakar
c'est possible ça pourrait effectivement
être une possibilité parce que on a
quand même vu ses deux échecs quelque
part 2015 2017 et en ayant progressé
comme on l'a fait je pense que le
chanceux sont plus grande même si cette
course est peut-être encore un peu plus
dur de par la période où après ses 600
km de désert on doit en général effecté
trois à quatre heures de route pour
rejoindre le bivouac et c'est peut-être
ce rythme là qui serait encore plus
compliqué à suivre
mais à voir voilà en tout cas avec la
même voiture avec la même voiture qui va
finir par être fiable à force de
travailler dessus et avec laquelle
finalement on a vécu une aventure
extraordinaire
merci à vous tous tristes on est passé
sur ce plateau on suivra avec attention
vos prochaines aventures et vous
reviendrez j'en suis sûr ici pour pour
commenter vos prochaines courses cela
merci à vous pour votre intérêt merci à
très bien sans beaucoup tristan hameau
de golf à présent la fédération
française a annoncé vouloir créer un
pôle élite pour les meilleurs jeunes
golfeurs de france à l'horizon 2020
pour cela un lieu a été ciblé le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
projet prévoit notamment une salle de
sport une aire d'entraînement au petit
jeu ainsi qu'un centre d'accueil pour 30
à 40 golfeur coût total de l'opération
près de 4 millions d'euros nous avons
joint par téléphone le directeur de la
fédération française de golf christophe
muniesa il nous explique les objectifs
de ce nouveau pôle c'est de continuer
évidemment de tout mettre en oeuvre pour
permettre à des joueurs français
d'intégrer le top 50 le truck le top 30
mondial et deux prétendre aux sélections
des futurs ryder cup ou solesmes cup
avec en ligne de mire l'objectif de
paris 2024 et d'essayer évidemment dit
d'aller chercher une médaille
on va maintenant parler fitness caddie à
baradji une habitante de
voisins-le-bretonneux est devenu en fin
d'année et miss fitness france 2010 9
après avoir déjà remporté le titre en
2018 quel est son secret pour réussir
cet exploit
j'ai pu tester un entraînement intensif
avec cette championne qui pratiquent le
sport 30 heures par semaine pour bart
courbatures garantie regarder
une session particulière aujourd'hui je
vais rencontrer 8,9 france 2018 et 2019
cali baradji qui nous vient tout droit
de voisins-le-bretonneux naturel comment
fait pour devenir miss fitness france
elle pour devenir miss fitness france
vous assez de l'entraînement je
m'entraîne beaucoup il faut être bons
jeunes à peu près 30 heures par semaine
moteur concours et d'entraînement et
donc je fais du cardio et de la
musculation il faut coupler les deux
pour être la miss fitness il faut avoir
un profil assez complet mais c'est quoi
le programme aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va je vous ai prévenus
pas mal de choses
on va tester mon entraînement à moi mais
avant on va s'échauffer bien sûr bon
c'est parti je vais me changer c'est
parti et après on fait trop de sérieux
c'est parti
[Musique]
un peu peur parce que kddi a l'air sûr
motivé en tout cas pour me faire
souffrir
on va voir ce que ça donne mais
l'optimiste on meurt toujours quoi de
cardiaque libéral il faut pas être
cardiaque apparemment donc qu'en dira ne
suis pas je me suis pas votre guerrier
bien ça passe en mode koh lanta koh
lanta
[Musique]
bravo ça va mal cardio super commence à
monter chez au top
du coup on va commencer par réchauffer
une cuisse donc on va faire des squats
de simples
et on comprend des couettes avec doc et
beaucoup le mot simple squat simple tu
descends
et tu montes ça va ça va ça va
très bien
ça fait 3
4 c'est perturbant
c'est ce qu'on s'est dit
[Musique]
on va faire un petit peu de pont donc on
commence par des pompes aussi sur la
botte
d'affaires 5
donc là c'est le moment que j'appréhende
le plus vraiment dans cette session est
apparemment de cadix on sort très bien
moi j'adore faire des ponts inquiète
tout le monde a à a
allez
1 ouais 2
pourquoi à
4 encore une 4
parce que tu fais tous les jours
ah oui tous les jours je fais des
fonctions obligé combien minimum pour
soumaré val d'is
et puis dans la journée elle s'est
produit quelques minutes son oui
évidemment on s'ennuyait dans une jatte
et à boire de l'eau comme angers ont
tout leur temps au quai des pompes
[Musique]
à les voir jouer
oui
à
ouah après une séance à votre caddie on
voit que tout de suite
ce porte ses fruits
voilà maintenant on va dire que j'arrive
à faire des tractions assez facilement
je conseille à tout le monde essayait au
moins une fois une session
d'entraînement et kddi a baradji en
passe maintenant à notre page agenda
[Musique]
on va parler voile dans cet agenda si
vous voulez connaître les sensations
d'un skipper pendant vendée globe se fit
peut vous intéresser
le navigateur versailles et éric bellion
a présenté jeudi dernier à versailles
son film baptisé comme un seul homme qui
retrace son parcours en totale immersion
des images de patrick jacques de dixmude
à montage de jules haag relève yves il a
réalisé le vendée globe en 2017 et il
veut nous le raconter dans un film
intitulé comme un seul homme éric
bellion vous êtes avec moi le versailles
et eric qu'est ce que ce film raconte
assez le sait l'histoire du vendée globe
mais ce qu'on a jamais vu en fait c'est
à dire que c'est le cheminement
intérieur le film commence à la première
manoeuvre il se termine avant que les
premiers zodiac arrive donc c'est tout
ce qui se passe quand on perd le bateau
de vue et jusqu'à ce qu'on le redécouvre
et donc c'est tout ce cheminement
intérieur le fait d'aller au delà de sa
peur de se rencontrer et j'essaie de le
raconter avec le plus de sincérité
possible
donc voilà et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ce film est tourné
on n'avait pas le choix on va le dire
mais à la première personne avec une
gopro est le film à bout de bras et
j'essaie d'embarquer le spectateur comme
s'ils vivaient le vendée globe avec moi
comme si on faisait le vendée globe à 2
c'est assez chouette et d'où t'est venue
l'idée de ce film
moi j'avais très envie de raconter
justement ce cheminement puisque ce fait
15 ans que je monte des aventures pour
donner envie aux gens de faire quelque
chose différent avec des gens différents
et je voulais raconter tout ce qui se
passe quand on décide de faire quelque
chose qu'on n'a jamais fait la pearl
envies d'abandon la fatigue les risques
qu'on prend et puis après ce qu'on
découvre de l'autre côté du miroir
c'est à dire le fait qu'on a des
ressources infinies le fait qu'on peut
créer de la confiance avec soi même avec
les autres et puis le bonheur l'état de
grâce qu'on peut découvrir après avoir
franchi toutes les étapes
est ce qu'il ya des moments forts dans
ce film même si on veut pas tout
raconter au public
ben je crois que que des moments très
forts parce que ça c'est une aventure
ultime
moi j'avais jamais fait de solitaire
avant de partir sur le vendée globe
donc tout est une découverte chaque jour
est une aventure et il ya des moments de
colère énorme et à des moments de peur
énorme les moments de bonheur
extraordinaire c'est c'est un yoyo
permanent et surtout vous vous en sortez
avec l'impression vraiment vous venez de
faire le vendée globe est ce qui est des
moments où tu a craqué dans cette
aventure
oui oui j'ai plusieurs fois j'ai pensé
abandonner plusieurs fois j'ai craqué
parce que pour moi le défi était trop et
je savais pas que j'avais les épaules
pour aller le réaliser donc plusieurs
fois je suis pris de désespoir mais
comme nous tous quand quand on affronte
un défi qui nous dépasse pas les moments
de désespoir et là j'en ai vécu plein et
ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est que
c'était son premier vendée globe
également un vrai c'était le premier
vendée globe
probablement le dernier et c'est vrai
que tout était tout été une aventure une
découverte
donc c'était extrêmement riche avoir une
caméra filmer au quotidien ça t'a pas
pris de trop de temps justement quand on
sait que les manoeuvres des fois se joue
au millimètre sur une compétition comme
celle là non je ne sais pas j'ai pas
ressenti le fait que ça me prenne trop
de temps c'est vraiment quelque chose
que je voulais donc c'était pour moi
aussi important que bien faire marcher
mon bateau et puis j'avais des caméras
facilement atteignables donc je pouvais
les déclencher quand j'avais quelque
chose à dire ou quand je ressentais
quelque chose de fort je voulais
vraiment le communiqué c'était très
important pour moi de le partager au
maximum comme un seul homme pour quoi
c'est un cri de guerre comme un seul
homme c'est on peut tous est différent
et agir comme un seul homme
voilà c'est également le nom ton bateau
c'est le nom du bateau c'est non toutes
les aventures je monte et une nouvelle
aventure qui arrive qui s'appelle encore
comme un seul homme
l'idée c'est vraiment de regrouper des
hommes et des femmes qui ont décidé
d'explorer la différence et ne pas avoir
peur de l'autre
quel impact tu aimerais que ce film est
auprès du public j'aimerais que ce film
aide les gens à réaliser
la chose qu'ils ont en eux et qu'ils
n'osent pas faire j'aimerais que ce film
permettent aux gens d'arrêter de se
recroqueviller dans l'antre soi et
s'ouvrir à la différence tout simplement
il ya un message philosophique derrière
ce film ouais message philosophique et
j'ai pas peur de le dire un message
politique au sens noble du terme dans la
peur y'a rien de bon et on n'y peut rien
se passer de bon avec la peur une fois
qu'on dépasse la peur là on peut se
découvrir soi-même et on découvre aussi
la relation à l'autre et on devient
heureux on crée on réussit des choses
qu'on pouvait pas imaginer dans ce film
qui parle que de toi ou tu parle
également d autres skippers qui ont
participé à l'aventuré
c'est vraiment au plus près de moi donc
c'est un vraiment je voulais que le
spectateur soit témoin de ce cheminement
intérieur et puis se projeter aussi
moi je suis un mec lambda je suis pas un
athlète de haut niveau j'ai décidé un
jour de dalé partir sur des globes parce
que c'était un rêve mais c'était quelque
chose d'assez inaccessible et je veux
vraiment que les spectateurs se disent
je peux faire ça aussi mon vendée globe
c'est pas forcément cette course là ça
peut être n'importe quoi mais je peux le
faire donc c'est pour ça je parle très
peu de la course c'est pas un film sur
la voile ou sur la course c'est vraiment
un film sur soi la peur le dépassement
c'est plutôt ça les thèmes principaux
tu es à participer à la dernière route
du rhum également est-ce que tu as
réalisé un film là bas ou est-ce qu'il
faut pas encore en parler
non j'ai pas réalisé de film c'était une
exploration interne extrêmement forte
que j'ai voulu voir vérifier si ce que
j'avais vécu de fabuleux sur le vendée
globe je pouvais le vivre en décélérant
donc j'ai vendu le bateau de course et
j'ai acheté une goélette très belle mais
très lourde et j'ai essayé de revivre ce
bonheur sur l'eau en allant vraiment
nettement moins vite ça a été
extrêmement difficile mais c'est arrivé
et j'ai découvert un bonheur encore plus
durable mais je n'ai pas raconter en
films je les raconte et surtout en texte
et là je suis en train d'écrire un livre
donc aujourd'hui on est à versailles au
cirano de versailles qu'est ce que ça te
fait elle sert à dos et le cinéma de mon
enfance donc c'est là que j'ai vu les
mes premiers films
c'est là où j'ai
mon premier baiser d'adolescents donc
c'est un endroit très spécial pour moi
c'est très très heureux et très fier de
montrer le film ici tu voulais
absolument qui passe ici en
avant-première
ah oui oui c'était très important pour
moi quel est l'avenir pour ce film sorti
le 13 février c'est ça voilà il sort le
13 février là on parcourt la france pour
faire des avant-premières et puis on va
bien voir comment il est reçu par les
spectateurs j'espère que il ya un bouche
à oreille qui va se mettre en place et
que les gens vont avoir envie d'aller
voir ce film mais je ne sais pas
j'espère je fais tout pour en tout cas
merci beaucoup éric bellion comme un
seul homme sortira le 13 février
prochain dans les salles
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]